this guy looks like he would have came
to our store you know
and you know what my mom says because
i'm concerned she's like oh don't worry
about me
if someone comes up to me with a gun i'm
gonna
praise the lord she said i'd be so happy
i finally get to go to heaven
that was her mentality she's like don't
worry about me
all right all right you you're fine
i was so concerned for her in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
we have our buddy ed parkvp what's up
here again today
cheers so we're just gonna get right
into the subject
just because it happened probably uh the
other day
and uh you know usually when these
events happen
i get a lot of dms right right like hey
can you talk about this can you talk
about this which i which i do understand
and what i'm talking about right now
is the the shooting that happened out in
uh atlanta uh atlanta does have a huge
asian population out there
yeah huge black and asian population if
you guys haven't heard about this
you most likely did it it's literally
all over the place right
right um there was a it's a massage
parlor right or like a spot like a day
spa
yeah i might it says young spa
yeah whatever i don't know if it's a
chimchibang but you get your massages
there
um i don't think yeah yeah it's just
i don't know if it's a monsoon spot or
like a nail salon or something like that
it just says spa
yeah it's a spar nation we have right so
a man walks in
a white male walks in and just starts
blasting people up
long story short you guys could read the
articles for yourself but eight people
were were murdered not including just
the workers there was people who were
this there for the massage services as
well and there was a few other people
that went to the hospital
uh pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah uh in light
of everything that's been happening
specifically to the asian american
community and
and everything else and you know i've
done uh quite a few videos on this
and i've talked about it a lot and uh
people ask me to do instagram videos and
[ __ ] but sometimes it's like
how can i convey a lot of these
complicated thoughts within
a [ __ ] one-minute window you know
right
i can't really do it there's too much to
unpack here right
and we've seen this recently too before
we even get into this article
i did a post about this where there's
everybody knows about this but they
didn't know about the the outcome of
what happened there was a man in
oakland 75 year old man um that was
pushed to the floor
right from behind and if you guys have
been in the bay area or san francisco or
oakland it's a very hilly area
he was pushed down at a slant and then
he fell hit his head and he actually
died two days later
right and it was from this uh from this
man who
killed him he was number one
known for attacking people yeah he has
like it's been reported multiple times
that he's been attacking elderly asian
people
and law enforcement didn't do anything
about it
right um now this man had to die for it
right um the the reason why i posted it
on instagram and the reason why i was
like so [ __ ] mad was number one
75 year old man went out his whole life
to die like that yeah like a [ __ ]
stray dog in the streets [ __ ]
terrible second problem that i had with
that
i was trying to find a photo of him and
it was the hardest thing to find
except for this one blurry ass photo of
this man articles or whatever there was
hardly anything and it was only located
in the bay area
but i couldn't find a decent photo of
this dude and i'm like why the [ __ ]
is it that i can't find a photo of this
guy
because i was trying to post it on a
story yeah so i had to take a screen cap
from abc from the article that they had
of a video
that had a description of who he was at
the bottom yeah and it was
it was representative of like how number
one there's a couple of things that are
happening right
number one i feel that um
asian people are a very small subset of
of this country's population right 5.6
right so no matter how many times we
speak up how many times we say something
we don't have a large enough voice for
it to kind of reach a lot of people
because i guarantee you
five point six percent only about maybe
one percent maybe even half a percent
are really talking about this right
so that's already an issue in and of
itself right
right number two it kind of goes to the
fact that where we have this
conversation where
sometimes when we talk about asian
subjects it's not really taken very
seriously
even if we're like killed in the middle
of the street it's just kind of like oh
a lot of people have been saying stuff
like oh well you know
other people have problems too it's like
right what does that have to do with
this person that was just murdered in
the military you know
and you're telling us to like
invalidating
how we feel about it like hey other
people get hurt too it's like
no [ __ ] and we're out here telling you
that we're hurt
you know feels like well don't be
yeah it does really feel like that right
like
i have a i have an issue with
it's something that i that i've always
mentioned before right it's where people
enjoy the act of activism
they enjoy being involved in it but
they're not really
active in their activism right because
as of right now
we understand why a lot of people did
blm because if they didn't they felt
that they were gonna get persecuted
they're gonna be called a racist
or they got brownie points for it yeah
well you're not gonna get brownie points
for asian people suffering
so you know it took it took this
incident for there to be a mass murder
of eight people
i'm sorry that the the one person dying
out in the middle of the street i'm
sorry
that wasn't enough or the multiple times
that a 75 or 80 year old person was
attacked in middle street
they had oil splattered on them they
were burned right
they were slashed in the face with
knives they were pushed down in the
middle of streets and murder
that wasn't enough but it took a [ __ ]
mass shooting and then people are like
hey maybe we should take this seriously
it's like [ __ ] man yeah
it's not like we we have we saw those
new
that news we saw that [ __ ] happening i
saw that happening
in my life personally um shared those
stories
at my store you know and i
got to my store when trump was
inaugurated
you know well yeah and in my point of
view
my subjective bubble from where i was
everyone treated me like [ __ ] because
they felt
empowered by this guy the president yeah
trump at the time like i
i hate being that guy of taking it there
but i grew up in the area too and
between the four years i lived there
and moved out and went back
there was this empowerment right this
empowerment where they felt like
they are allowed to say this to us like
i've always thought it but now that he
said well i can say it yeah i had a
[ __ ]
60 plus year old woman told me to get
out of this country because trump's
gonna kick me out
you know yeah it's like once you're
alive during like i don't know the civil
rights movement how can you be saying
this
yeah i i i saw it coming sp
i mean it was happening to me and
i had this thought that
if i you know hung out in seattle and
fed away with all the other
you know koreans and asians in tacoma
you know people leave me alone
kind of thing but what i realized was
that the
asian community i was hanging out with
had no
clue what these attacks were about yeah
at the time they were happening to me
so even if i said they called me a [ __ ]
or a [ __ ] they have no idea
what to do with it you know thank god
i'm not dead
yeah but i was getting assaulted you
know
[ __ ] was yeah vandalized all these
things
and i see now people having
not knowing what to do but trying to do
something right
and they only know the surface level of
what to do and that's what you're saying
this
social activism right like you get that
brownie because
it's in your story yeah yeah you
mentioned it once
kind of thing but i think it does tie
into what people don't know what to do
so they dm
you and they send you the articles and
they say you speak for us because what
do they want
i think they wanted you to just get
[ __ ] angry on camera
yeah and scream at this incel you know
like what's the point what is that going
to do like i'll speak when i feel it and
then if
i do it three or four times and doesn't
get through then i have to do a
different approach
right because doing the same thing over
and over expecting a different result is
the definition of insanity so
did that guy who shot up these you know
spas and these asian women
did he see your videos no he did not
even when you were featured by instagram
corporation itself on their
page do you think he saw that yeah he
was like holy [ __ ] i had no idea
and then now i think it's ridiculous if
anyone tells you you're not doing enough
you were on the [ __ ] ig
page dude the front page of that [ __ ]
your future like you're speaking out
about this
yeah it's ridiculous for them to to want
to
i have to say like you're the voice of
things yeah this is this is the thing
too it's like
that backseat activism of you expecting
somebody else to do your work for you is
[ __ ] stupid
like you have to understand something
dude the biggest biggest way to create
impact is by numbers
numbers yeah you could have a million
people behind a [ __ ] desk
sit back and ask other people to do
something is different when those
million people actually do it for
themselves
it is highly different yeah and so when
you ask
i understand when you ask somebody with
the bigger platform to speak up
it's going to happen but what do you do
after i do it do you just sit back and
say
he did it for us and then you go back
and chill right that's not the point
then it gets forgotten yeah it gets 100
forgotten
and so like with these issues too right
you see this situation
the stuff blows up and then one of the
things let me tell you something this
might sound a little incredulous right
but i was kind of glad that this person
was white
you know why not because i hate white
people or something but the biggest
rhetoric
right now was that this is a propaganda
against the black community
and i kept hearing it over and over and
i'm like no no no no
this is a representation of how america
feels
america about asian people it just
happened to be
that those few people in that area which
has a lot of black they're the ones that
attack but it doesn't just happen with
black people
it's just it's americans in general
about when
we feel a certain way because we haven't
really spoken up about a lot of these
things because
in asian culture whining like a little
[ __ ] is not a part of our [ __ ]
we are the bootstrap culture we [ __ ]
deal with our own [ __ ]
we say you know what i'm gonna deal with
my own personal problems i got bigger
fish to fry
you guys worry about the small [ __ ] for
some reason in this translation we got
lost as
us being [ __ ] weak when we're the
business owners we're the ones that are
in the top two percent of the [ __ ]
schools so how the [ __ ] are we weak
i mean the [ __ ] does that make sense and
that's the mentality carried
um with america right like even in
sports right they still don't believe
that like
uh there's like i'm gonna say ichiro
right because i love baseball
every scout obama was like he yeah he's
not gonna make us he's too weak
he's too weak he's too skinny even
jeremy lin they told him
his athleticism is diffusing uh
deceiving
or yeah young waku you can say a whole
lot about just the mentality behind it
especially because it's how i felt
is like america thinks that we're yeah
we
are below them like this of ma in
masculinity
quote-unquote just these ideas that
we're below them so that's why i kept
getting this
the [ __ ] from old white guys at my store
like
for seeing what happened i see this
picture of this guy the suspect in this
shooting he looks like a guy who [ __ ]
goes to my store
yeah the [ __ ] big carhart and the
neck beard and everything you know
and just know you have a neck beard
you're going to shoot up somebody
you [ __ ] shake that [ __ ] off your
bastards it's like
this i i see that and it made me call my
mom i called my mom yeah this morning
you know and then i mentioned that this
guy looks like he would have came to our
store
you know and you know what my mom says
because i'm concerned she's like oh
don't worry about me
if someone comes up to me with a gun i'm
gonna
praise the lord she said
i'd be so happy i finally get to go to
heaven
that was her mentality she was like
don't worry about me i'm like
all right all right you're you're fine
i was so concerned for her your mom is
[ __ ]
funny dude if somebody shoot amma
i just get to see jesus a lot faster
that's exactly exactly what she said
your mom is [ __ ] nuts hey she's at
peace
i mean what is it saying that i know
like
we have a level of like empathy we see
what's happening i called my mom because
i saw that six
women were killed yeah you know but you
get down to it
like that's my american maybe empathy
come on all that [ __ ] my mom in her
korean ass mind is just
like that's not me yeah you know it's
tragic she understands it's crazy it's a
crazy world out there i'm taking care of
my own
yeah she's fine and she keeps telling me
don't worry about me
that's that's how a lot of asian people
think though you know you know
yeah and like i'm saying it's the tides
are changing a lot
because the generation is different from
the one before us
right right because our generation
before they were so
busy just trying to keep the [ __ ]
lights on build this business
learn how this country works yeah the
idea of worrying about this
quote-unquote bigger group of
asian plight wasn't a part of like the
lexicon or just like the list of things
that they had to worry about or the fact
that people were calling them soup
yeah you know hey cook i'm like that
sounds delicious
now i'm hungry yeah you know like people
were just screaming and it's like it's
the last thing they could care about
it's like i don't [ __ ] care i got
bills to pay say whatever the [ __ ] you
want
and that's why we've been able to build
businesses that's why a majority of
these asian immigrant kids
they go to universities they go into
higher levels of education because we've
been
taking advantage of what this country
has to offer so there's a
different mentality when you look at it
right sometimes or
not even sometimes in this country
people people have this idea of
like not saying something as being a
sign of weakness yeah it's different
it's culturally it's religiously
different too yeah you know
sometimes philosophically different it's
philosophically different right
and so it's hard to to really explain
this to somebody who doesn't grow up
in our culture right sometimes opening
your [ __ ] mouth about everything
doesn't really solve anything we might
as well just do stuff behind the scenes
and become better about it
but how this country works it doesn't
we're finding out it doesn't work in
this system
yeah you know and i'm seeing that it's
it's people who are just saying hey
don't you know it's time to be angry
right now
why aren't you angry and maybe my
[ __ ] adrenaline is spent
yeah maybe i have seen it so much in my
own personal life
uh it gives me anxiety and i sometimes
don't want to
touch it kind of thing i'm going to do
my best on my own and call my mom
you know but i
i honestly don't understand the activism
behind it
yeah like i'm not don't understand don't
know what activism is
yeah behind it for us you know is it
we're
talking about this too and i'm pretty
sure somebody out there has a good
answer for this right
um when people ask me to it's like okay
you you can donate to
all these asian american aapi stuff
right i'm like cool
what does that money go into right
that's my question
is it for our education we kill it at
that
yeah is it for like our financial stuff
i think financially a lot of the asian
americans i know
whether it's we work three or four jobs
like we we figured out a way
you know is it because we have like
neighborhoods where you know
we're like in substandard conditions
what what what is it that'll allow us
to level up in this in this world like
economically
and i think that for for me how i view a
lot of things
is that money equals power yeah and a
lot of asian people
because they're business owners they
hustle really hard we have that part
locked
yeah so is that money going into what
awareness like
what what is the objective they're
paying graphic designers man
you know yeah what is the objective is
my my question right
and uh like i'm saying i'm not dissing
it you know like we don't
know yeah and then there but they're
throwing this [ __ ] at us like do
something
do something what is this something yeah
aside from getting angry or talking
about it on social media which by the
way
when you post a lot of things i i
appreciate i think it makes a lot of
sense so you create this voice
but there has to be an after portion
like what happens after
clearly we are people without a plan
you know i think other people don't
realize that they don't have a plan and
they're going to action
yeah immediately you know but the first
action they know is social media which
is fair
yeah do that you know but then like
really really the next
how are we going to stop all this kind
of thing it it
who has that answer yeah i i think it's
just going to take some time
because like i said before our previous
generation were they we were so silent
because we had so much other stuff to
deal with yeah so now it's like we're at
the cusp and we're at the beginning
of something of a new movement so our
why isn't as strong as everybody
right now let's just [ __ ] give us
respect us like [ __ ] human beings
yeah
let's let's start with that i saw i i
don't know how it came because i'm going
through twitter uh trending
and kim kardashian literally says asians
are humans too
like [ __ ] i can't believe people have
to be reminded
asians are humans yeah that's what has
to happen
because we can't have you know like our
own movement it has to be
asians are humans yeah good god that's
where we are that's like michael shea
stand up he goes i can't believe that
people are angry about the statement
black lives matter yeah
that matters more not matters less just
matters
yeah and so it's ridiculous at this
point that we have to remind
americans hey we're in your same species
it's it's weird like the the concept of
when we
talk about our problems yeah right we're
either
said that we're we are very disingenuous
because
what about somebody else's problems it's
like okay so i don't say anything right
and then somebody else yells at first
well you guys have to do something about
your culture because we can't do it for
you
what the [ __ ] do you want like what the
[ __ ] do you want from us
here's the thing too i people may or may
or not
may or may not agree with this but
really think about the [ __ ]
this to me is definitive of the asian
american experience right
it's like we are always being pushed and
pulled to somebody else's side but when
it comes to our own voice it gets
ignored why
i no joke hate it so [ __ ]
much right if it if it was blm i was
there for it i wanted to speak up about
it right and then someone
was calling me a [ __ ] blm pawn right
and i'm like okay
whatever then i don't say something
about it or i stay quiet for a little
bit because i'm processing my own
thoughts
and they go oh you're over here just
being complacent about the white man
and then we're over here being used as
the model minority for white people to
say well look at you black folks
you can't do it like asian people we're
being pulled from so many different
angles and then when it comes time for
us to be like yo hold on a second
our people are being killed how can we
address it they go oh look at these
[ __ ] just [ __ ] whining
it's like wait the [ __ ] do you want yeah
like
if when it comes to each other's stuff i
think even some liberals out there when
they might not understand that they're
saying the pull yourself by the
bootstraps
rhetoric in a different language but
they're saying it out of resentment
instead not because they don't care or
empathize they know
like this is a same level of murder
yeah it's murder you know and it is
racially involved people were
like even the sheriff there was trying
to say he had a bad day
you know he had a sex edition it's not
racially they live that's the official
statement
you know but we know that it's not but
we're not out there like
having to try to [ __ ] correct this
guy he's gonna figure it out yeah that's
not the most
important issue at the moment the the
hard part about
the the sheriff or whatever going out on
a public platform and saying that
and i've said this multiple [ __ ]
times is that when it comes to a place
of importance and power
your rhetoric matters yeah how you speak
[ __ ] matters it goes back to that
concept of
the kung flu and china virus it's
because they
aren't caring about us yeah that they
would rather put in front that this guy
this guy had problems and that's why he
did this and that's why kim kardashian
has to say hey asians are
humans
like listen you [ __ ] no [ __ ] he has
[ __ ] problems yeah but the fact
that that is the point that you're
trying to make during this speech
when eight people were killed in a mass
shooting
is very very disappointing and it's
offensive like why do why do people not
understand like i understand when you're
in a group of people and friends you
could say that to your little [ __ ]
group and maybe they'll understand where
you're coming from right right
but you are in a position of power you
were on a public platform
and the point that you wanted to make
was that hey y'all
god was having a bad day and this this
kid masturbates too much
and that's why he ought to kill some
[ __ ] gooks
it's their fault you know like i
understand too
just to okay let me just play the other
side he was kind of quoting the reason
that he gave
he gave to the cops because the mass
shooter sets up
yeah i okay maybe he was just quoting
what he said yeah
having said that and giving him the
benefit of the doubt of that
you're still at a public platform where
you should be smarter
about the [ __ ] that you [ __ ] say
people just died you just
like who the f it's like when somebody
passes away right
let's say i'm at your mother's funeral
i come up to you and i say your mom and
your you know let's say your mom was
like
obese right that goes your mom died
because she had a lot of kit kats
yeah and then you go i'm sorry for your
loss
like you know how the [ __ ] would you how
the [ __ ] would you feel
oh my god it was like kit kats huh yeah
and that was like it's true her favorite
[ __ ] candy
you know was it the right time to say
that probably [ __ ] not guy
yeah you know and it's hard for and
like i'm saying i'm trying to play both
sides because i you know i took the
whole morning to think about this yeah
and it was i'm probably gonna need a
couple more days i'm gonna limbo at that
too i'm not
it's not about the both sides like
there's
all these thoughts out there and we're
trying to bring these spider webs
together right
it's like we don't know yet and we're
not gonna act like we do
yeah the day it happens yeah it's it's
hard to process it because
you know this guy said that yeah i shot
it he was actually gonna go out and do a
few more shootings if he wasn't caught
right
and he said that he has a sex addiction
and these peop these places
tempted him and that's why he killed him
it wasn't race motivated now when we say
things like
race motivated i think what people are
trying to define it as
is he came into the store and he was
like
you know trump said it's okay
we're not saying that he's as if hey
card carrying member of the kkk
yeah it wasn't really that yeah you know
race motivation or racism can have a lot
of different flavors
right he probably had an asian fetish
yeah right he couldn't get an asian
woman to talk to him most definitely so
he felt like the best way to do it was
to get rid of his frustrations by
killing asian women
that's also race motivated as well it's
not in your specific definition
of trump said kung flu therefore
go and kill the salon yeah it's not that
black and white
no right it's also race motivated as
well it's a lack of respect for our
women it's a lack of respect for our
culture
we can get into a whole conversation how
a lot of people in this country have a
lack of respect for asian women yeah you
guys look at asian women sometimes as
these
little tiny little [ __ ] dolls we hear
about it all the time little tight [ __ ]
little creatures
right and i and you know that in and of
itself is [ __ ] disgusting
right and it's the fetishization that we
were talking about that happens
it's in this country it's just such a
weird situation to be
for me to i don't know why i have to
explain this [ __ ] and then have people
come back and call and say that i'm
being weak
i feel like i'm living in a twilight
zone because if one of your family
members were killed right and people
were mourning and grieving would you
come back and tell them like hey man
stop it you're weak bro damn you [ __ ]
what a little [ __ ] man yeah you know i
think
people need to understand too like if
this guy went to the first location
and shot up four people then he drove
30 miles to the next location which was
also an asian spa
how was that not race motivated
and then he went across to another asian
spa but it's not race motivated
yeah right and they're like there's
bigger fish to fight and i just feel
there's general rhetoric like before i
was like kind of
mentioning how that there's bigger
problems than this that
oh it's about gun control or it's it's
about
uh some other [ __ ] thing rather than
the fact that asian women were murdered
you know and that like literally taking
out the race aspect of it
and being like reports say well the
korean
newspaper said that four of them were
actually korean
women with and like one of the witnesses
that survived in korean
translation saying that he came in
wanting to kill asian women
yeah and i was seeing it as this media
bias difference too you know it could be
that
korea is just like you know like just
really wanting to push the picture like
asians
are being attacked in america all right
they do that
you know in american media trying to be
like this isn't a problem it wasn't race
motivated
or whatever how does that affect any of
us
right now what control do we have
between these two
bits of information right besides the
way it affects the way you
malfunction with your anger you know
with your hate your resentment because
of the past and how
things keep coming up because no one's
talking about it
like a lot of the behavioral health
therapy that i have to take in
is to just be like what's in my control
what can
i actually do yeah yeah what can i
actually do and
outside of being getting angry yeah and
even for this guy too it's just
the the the concept of he was having a
bad day
[ __ ] i had a bad day yesterday i didn't
go shoot up a [ __ ] salon
anyway i've had so many bad days yeah
you know what i'm saying like what the
[ __ ] kind of reasoning is that
i've had i had a bad day you know what i
did i ate some food
and and you know what like a personal
trainer might say he might give you some
[ __ ] for that
you want to be like you know what you
had a bad day a man who's supposed to
enforce the [ __ ]
law the sheriff is saying he had a bad
day
and look at the way we see it in our
shoes
you don't give a [ __ ] yeah do you he he
doesn't care yeah
and so we get that we get it but we're
not like gonna
spend the entire hour being angry at
this one guy that we don't know or have
any connection to
it's kind of like the level of reaction
was a shocking for me
you know like you could tell it's like
oh this is a travesty not like i can't
believe this happened it's more like
oh [ __ ] i can't some people died and
that's what it felt like it was very
disheartening
and i'm like you we're not talking about
somebody who came in and shot a single
human being which is terrible in and of
itself
yeah how can eight people die man people
that is a
mass shooting i don't know if it's
because people are desensitized to this
[ __ ] now
or because i i understand too like it's
gotten to that point where
you know we talk about 911 yeah i can
remember 911 like it was yesterday yeah
i can remember those twin towers on this
it was i was in a portable
the portables right so there was like
those the portable classrooms
we walked up the ramp sat down mr
tabarras was like
hey kids sit down we're gonna have to
watch this came in and we saw this clip
of a plane flying into
a building exploding the whole room was
dead silent
right the lights were off because we
were he had it on the tv
and we all just sit there with them sat
there with our mouth open like
what looked like an independence day
yeah it was like it felt like our
our whole world was crashing down yeah
and then we have situations where
the las vegas shooting happened not too
long ago where a man was sniping people
from a [ __ ] roof
and then people don't even remember that
[ __ ] they talk about it like it just
happened
like it never happened at all yeah like
are we getting desensitized to these
like acts of violence are we getting
desensitized to all this
terrible [ __ ] that's happening now like
what has what has media done to our
hearts i feel like it's calloused us
it's like i i no kidding about that
because you
sip through it and you have to
actually go out of your way to just
find like a source of news that's just
good news
yeah it's i know that it's like
bad news cells right bad news gets
eyeballs
you know um and that's where like people
are getting desensitized because the
news has just told us this
there's nothing good going on yeah like
this whole world is terrible
yeah and it makes me not want to see
things sometimes you know that's why
sometimes i live in my own bubble
one of the biggest reasons why i moved
into like a suburb area was because
being in the city was depressing me
yeah you know just being around some of
the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] bags
yeah and i chose to kind of escape from
that
and just visit those areas instead of
living it yeah because
you know you know how many times were we
in k-town and then it was like
okay who's going to start some [ __ ] when
we're at this bar where we're at
yeah you know what i mean what's gonna
happen next you know like how many times
like i remember when we went i went to
uh
uh tobang yeah right one time i was i
was at tobong
and um we were just chilling and i i
just parked my car
there was a security guard that was
giving me [ __ ]
and i was waiting for a table at tobank
he was like you need to get the [ __ ] out
of here like stop loading i was like
i was there for that i think i remember
yeah what
i was like the [ __ ] i was gonna [ __ ]
that dude up like i was so [ __ ]
pissed
like the [ __ ] is your problem like
getting into this dude's [ __ ] face
and i'm like
no this city is [ __ ] nuts you know
like we're just
dealing with [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time
having to deal with this stuff right i
don't know how many times in that
chapman plaza i almost threw hands
dude told my chairman plaza okay so i
was there with some seattle friends
like 10 of them had visited on some
massive group trip
yeah and so they want to go to long okay
cool we hung out
and at the end of the night
there is a table full of dudes and you
see him in k-town every now and then
there's some thugs you know some
gangsters who knows what they are
i think i saw the table i seen who they
were and i went to my table
you know and whatever that's fine and
then
uh at the end of the night we're leaving
there was
a group of like four white girls like
and one white dude right
and those guys started hitting on those
girls
right and then this guy started becoming
captain
likes just like yeah
it's pretty much like hey man leave it
alone leave her in like she doesn't want
to talk to you
you know and then this guy took his hat
off
full forehead just all over his head
oh [ __ ] i was like oh my god and i
i went in there and i was like hey man
look at him come on man he's not from
here he's not from k-town yeah you know
i was just like hey chill
yeah he's not from here dude yeah and
then i turned around to this
dude right and i grabbed him by the
collar and i said get the [ __ ]
out of here and i shoved him and i
turned around and went like hey dude i'm
trying to have fun
and i hear the white guy i'm gonna come
over my shoulder like [ __ ] you man try
to act hard all of a sudden i was like
oh my god
i grabbed him again i said get out and i
pushed him
and then a [ __ ] fist went across his
face and
of course they
and there's a little bit of water in
there before it was like filled up he
started trying to drown him in there
he was [ __ ] choking his ass in the
water
so i actually went in and grabbed this
guy i don't even know he is yeah i was
like stop stop stop don't kill him yeah
don't
kill him yeah and he said [ __ ] you too
bye i got
hit right inside the head i said all
right i walked away
yeah and he got the [ __ ] [ __ ] kicked
out of him inside of that fountain he
wouldn't stop
i couldn't believe that this guy would
not stop ruthless ruthless
jesus and then they left right this
guy's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up and then one of the white
girls was like oh i expected this out of
you asians
this is what it's like and i ran up to
her
and i said hey that's racist yeah
that right there is racist yeah stop
that you know
and i looked at the guy his face was
mangled yeah he was getting swollen he
looked like an
alien what the [ __ ] did he think he was
gonna do it's like bro
exactly are you out of your mind i said
i told you to get out of here didn't i
i said get out of here and it's in the
mango face because yeah
yeah you told me
i was like you shouldn't listen to me
dude yeah
i understand why you don't exactly want
to
i was like listen you tried to be a
[ __ ] tough guy yeah
somebody takes off their hat and they
have a tattoo on their
[ __ ] forehead you know what that
means they don't care about a
nine-to-five job
yeah which means they don't give a [ __ ]
about you yeah they will
literally beat your ass and you're lucky
they didn't [ __ ] kill you i'm trying
to be
the peacemaker and i got socked across
the head
you know and then i took after that
i saw one of these guys from uh blue
like or some restaurant he was carrying
a bag full of to go and he was
taking it to some other guy and that guy
who had just beat up that guy walked or
saw him walking
pushed him in the face too random guy he
kept walking he just pissed
you know it's just a badass move dude
bad movie that's what i'm telling you
you don't [ __ ] with certain people dude
like
i um one time i was going over to uh
cafe blue
and i didn't want to [ __ ] go but
there was a bunch of homies there i
walked up
and then literally as i'm about to walk
in so
i don't know what what set they're from
but there was like a young kid there
and i'm like i [ __ ] at somebody's
birthday i'm gonna
roll through i came up and this dude
this young kid came up to me and he put
his hand on my chest and what the [ __ ]
he goes
like you david still right he was like i
was like he went like this yeah i was
like what's up
he put his hand on my chest you didn't
sell right yeah he was hey don't go in
there right now
i'm like okay i got you
they [ __ ] jump the dude inside there
they beat the living [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
him
and i was like thank you sir yeah it's
like hey don't go in there right now and
i'm like i'll go appreciate it he was
like yeah like it's like he's like hey
man
i [ __ ] with your stuff
i [ __ ] with your stuff though i was like
thanks bro as
if we have our own reality to deal with
yeah right and we understand you know
the tragedy that happens out in our
country
we get it too right but then
like we have these things that we live
in you know as well and they
live through those same things but
like what are we going to do for them
like when we
have these issues ourselves where people
are also attacking us
and even in that situation too it's like
there's one white guy it's like you see
a bunch of asian dudes and for some
reason you think that it's going to be a
walk in the park
yeah they're going to [ __ ] you up yeah
and he learned otherwise and i'm pretty
sure
i said i'm not going to say it as if i
know it but there is something about
being disrespected by another ethnicity
that looks down on you that creates a
certain rage it's like cool
yeah you didn't respect me the first
time when this other person warned you
all these other people right here warned
you cool now i'm gonna make sure that
you remember who the [ __ ] i am and then
you're gonna know what's gonna happen
next
right that's why that dude wouldn't stop
beating his ass right make sure he
[ __ ] remembers yeah you know
there's a there's a certain level of
disrespect that you have for somebody's
like manhood
yeah you know as a human being that
makes them want to react a certain way
because you won't give them that simple
small amount of respect as a human being
so it's like cool
since you don't understand that i will
[ __ ] you up i'm gonna make sure that you
remember for the rest of your life and i
guarantee that dude is gonna think twice
about it yeah
you know i don't know the answer to this
and it's just the thought
too like in the asian mentality
do you think these asian immigrants
move to atlanta with the thought that
these people have guns
we don't they don't there's no guns in
asia or whatever and then they move
out there fully taking the risk that
people someone will shoot me
i mean absolutely not i think it's just
we
i think anybody who comes from an area
to move
here they think of it as the land of
promise right right so the only thing
they're thinking about is like look i
can make a living without having to
worry about a lot of things that i had
to worry about before
yeah i don't think death and being shot
is one of those things that are up there
right until you're approached with these
situations
right like my dad was also kind of like
your mom too my dad is a pastor
so you know for some reason our store
has never been robbed at gunpoint
i think it's also because we're very i
think we're respected in that community
like we treat everybody with respect you
know the people who get disrespect in
our store are people who are pieces of
[ __ ] anyways yeah and they don't [ __ ]
matter
so we developed a relationship with the
community so we're respected as such
but my dad too like he's he's you know
never had to worry about being shot or
killed our neighbors next to us
got robbed our neighbors to the left of
us got robbed stores down across from us
got robbed too but we never did
yeah but that's our reality yeah people
next to us were also korean
yeah they got robbed two or three times
before they finally moved right
so there is this idea of
we just kind of come here to work on
ourselves the
the the danger part isn't really a part
of it so that's why like when i when i
heard that story
i get real i got really i wasn't even
angry it was just so
sad because yeah could you imagine
just going into work and you're shot and
killed simply because
you are an asian woman that's it there
is no motive
you did nothing you said nothing you
spoke nothing you didn't do anything at
all
you woke up every day to make a living
for your family or yourself
and that's all the motive he needed to
kill you
that's it and the tragedy
like i said going back to that [ __ ] face
sheriff saying he had a
a sex addiction and people now
thinking that these women were [ __ ]
happy ending women
totally throwing them like as if like
that's why it's not like they deserve to
die for that yeah
you know and even if they were like it
was like they weren't under the radar as
a suspicious
area where they would do certain things
like that it was like something like
that written
how was it that like it's so normal for
us to just get full body massages god
damn it yeah i have a membership in
k-town
to [ __ ] go every week to get a full
body massage we need it
we are high stress people yeah our
muscles are tight yeah
but then everyone in but in america
it's upsetting yeah that you think it's
a hand job place yeah you know
is that why they deserve to die
because of his sex addiction and like
as far as all reports go that it was a
legit place you know
and that's what's more upsetting is that
like this is
like deep tissue massage is part of our
culture yet
you know you guys sexualized it and
that's the reason why he killed
them yeah i uh yeah that's where we
of course we're upset you know but what
do
you do beyond that except like you stop
[ __ ] thinking that way and how are
you gonna do that yeah
yeah like all all this
money that raising awareness like then
okay
we should hire graphic designers and
filmmakers to make commercials to tell
white people to stop fetishizing us
you know you know what's crazy it's i i
know a lot of people right now
that they they want to have a different
message from a lot of these asian events
the asian people that grow over a little
sketchy yeah
so the uh the the rhetoric of their
their their a conversation is
i'm just gonna start shooting people
like it's getting to that point yeah you
know
it's getting to that point where they're
like okay cool since you think that
we're a bunch of [ __ ] the next time i
see somebody approach me i'm just gonna
blast you
and that's just how it is you know we
can go back to
the the la riots and a lot of people
thought that these korean americans were
very passive human beings but they also
forgot
that these people who were there at the
korean rights they also went through the
korean war
yeah they um they went through
dictatorship and
murder murder murder by the government
four years in the military yeah they're
very well trained they know how to fire
guns and they're like yo how are these
people sniping us from a [ __ ] roof
like they're in the military yeah
because they were in the military
and we gotta and i i actually wanted to
bring that up
like um i see so many of my asian
american friends
who don't know a goddamn thing about the
riots you know
um speaking out against the second
amendment and have no idea that the
second amendment
saved koreatown yeah you know because
the cops
bounced you know yeah
and we use the second amendment to our
best ability and k-town still stands
today yeah
you know and for me that i understand
why like it's important like and why you
shouldn't abolish it but then
we all think in this binary nature that
it's on
or off no guns yes guns
abortion no abortion everything binary
plus minus on off yeah rather than the
nuance of just
how difficult everything is and
accepting that it is
like difficult yeah yeah that's that's
such a good way to put it too it's that
black and white thing that we always
talk about
it's if we get rid of guns nobody is
going to die
that's how binary people think and it's
never like that
and you can't keep comparing america's
situation with firearms with everybody
else
you have to look at the history of this
country and how this country was built
right there is a general fear of tyranny
here in this country
which is why that first amendment is
here in case the government tries to
[ __ ] us over
guess what we can be our own militia
like well that's [ __ ] dumb that's
stupid
however this country is very large it's
very vast
there's absolutely no way that people
can expect the law enforcement to
protect them when they
need them to be there and anything could
just [ __ ] go down like the riots
and there's nothing out to protect you
but yourself
yeah like this is why we have this
mentality that
we know we're out here by our on our own
and no one's going to help us
that's the thing it's like like i
thought about this when i was
uh you know when i do college shows
unless i'm flying out to like north
carolina south carolina right
i'm talking about there's a house and
then the next house is three miles
next to you what the [ __ ] is the cop
gonna come here
yeah you'd be there in a day yeah by
firelight like what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen no i'm gonna protect myself
yeah i'm not saying that i want to use
this thing but in case something does
happen i'd rather be the person alive
dealing with the court proceedings or
rather being the person that's dead
yeah no doubt yeah you know that's true
like i i have a general
fear of guns yeah but i don't ever want
somebody to take away my right to have
mine oh dude i i've been to the shooting
range i shot guns
and that's specifically the reason why i
don't like it because i fired one
and i saw the immense power in it and
what it does to people
it's it's made to kill people not
animals
people and i kind of had that
existentialness in that holding that
much power in my hand
and you can call me a [ __ ] or whatever
but like
i didn't want that in my hands i did not
you know
it would be hard it's hard to live with
that idea you know that you could take
somebody's life in an instant
you know um when i so
the first time i ever legally shot a gun
like i shot gun like that
you had to put it the first time i
illegally did yeah like i shot like a
homie's handgun like out you know
at the back of his house and [ __ ] yeah
just doing stupid [ __ ] right and there
would be this field well
sacramento is like a plaza now but
there's like this field there's like
this tree of movies like
they would shoot it right just for fun
just some ghetto like farm boy [ __ ]
um uh and i remember uh i hadn't shot a
gun since i was like
16. right right it's been a long time
this is when i was what maybe 26 27
right so bart calls me up right and this
is where we play basketball all the time
right he's going to say he's like hey
you try to shoot
shoot like shoot this weekend and i'm
like yeah [ __ ] i'm down yeah
i get my basketball shoe shoes on
okay yo i get my basketball shorts
i get my ball ready i'm ready he sends
me a location right
and i'm driving and i'm like this is the
farthest pass before
i've ever been to him i was like did he
rent out an estate or something
because it's literally the shooting
range is like in a dirt mountain side so
all i see is like cacti
shrubs and i'm going up this
mountainside i'm like this is a very odd
basketball court
wow you know i'm driving and i show up
and it says shooting range and i
connected i was like
oh you're trying to shoot and everyone
is wearing like
cargo pants boots and i look at bart i
was like bro
i thought we're playing ball dude he's
like why would you think that i was like
dude when have i ever shot [ __ ] guns
with you yeah you said shooting
yeah are you trying to shoot this
weekend and i'm like yeah i'm down
i thought you missed shoot hoops bro
like i had no
[ __ ] idea you know i was like and i
looked in my mind
never asked me to shoot a gun before i
did
how the [ __ ] was i i look like a dumbass
dude
i got the [ __ ] armband going and
everything i'm like oh my god the
basketball shorts
yeah i was like you got your flip-flops
and your bowling shoes ready to go to
denny's or some [ __ ] afterwards yeah
like [ __ ] man but that's when uh bart
and joe actually taught me how to use a
gun properly right
trigger safety how to put in a a mag how
to you know
check to see if a bullet doesn't see if
it's safe point up and down
um once i had that locked it allowed me
to
feel a little safer around the firearm
yeah however there wasn't a moment that
didn't leave my mind where i was like
then one of these guys can turn around
just shoot me in the phone
you know yeah but the bar was telling me
it's like well if somebody tries to
shoot you literally there's like 12
people that'll blast that [ __ ]
but if that guy's on a suicide mission
he's not going to [ __ ] care yeah so
that scared me
it literally scared me to be at a fire
range with other people did any
at one point or any point did you think
like i got to get me one of these
no i wanted a gun because i wanted to
customize it like i wanted to customize
my forerunner
it's not even the shooting part i wanted
to customize and make this dope ass gun
like you're going to get the soak on
that metal gear
snake like specifically um
uh what's it called you guys i don't
really know guns very well
uh but it was the first gun that i ever
shot was a glock i didn't know how much
you could
mod a glock like you can do a forerunner
like
so i got really geeked out on how to mod
a glock and like finding custom places
to make this [ __ ] so gangster
and i was like dude this is an expensive
hobby right and then we're doing
would i even shoot this and i and i
started looking up more about the
accessories than the actual gun so i was
looking up this accessory that's over
your [ __ ] bed stand
yeah where it literally hides a shotgun
in it
so you just oh not today and
and you could blast somebody there's
something else where it was like a
a wall mirror that kind of holds like a
keyholder and then literally
it's a fingerprint button it latches
down and a handgun's inside dude so i
got geeked out about the tech yeah
and then you're probably like oh i'm
gonna build like a secret door
let's go there but like batman [ __ ]
slide down and [ __ ] but i don't know how
to shoot it at all
i was just like yo this would be [ __ ]
dope if i could just so i hear something
and i just hit the button and the gun
comes out
i'm like this is [ __ ] sick and it's
like you know what i have like a 4 000
pound missile that runs on gas that's
kind of a weapon right yeah customize
your missile guys
put some better rubber on the wheels
then you know get a body kit
hey don't customize a gun yeah customize
your missile your personal home missile
aka your vehicle car the weird thing is
is like i have
problems with uh maybe shooting somebody
and i have
absolutely no [ __ ] problem getting a
bat and cracking somebody's head
which is way worse you know like
yeah i i remember when i was living at
the south pass house
and uh somebody was trying to break into
our garage
and abe was like a little creeped out by
me he was like
he's like dude you're [ __ ] scary i
was like why he goes dude
you were smiling i was like what do you
mean
you he's like you look genuinely happy
somebody was breaking it around you're
probably like this is my chance
yeah i was like ready to go i was like i
can't wait till i see this guy and i
just
break his kneecaps like i would
literally
break his legs until he could never walk
again and i'm thinking
[ __ ] like this i'm getting excited right
and it's like you're weird dude so look
at the difference
in your personal offense with someone
[ __ ] with you and your family
and your property and all that that's
your problem
yeah and maybe that's part of the asian
philosophy that people
aren't seeing in us that you might
mistake
for apathy that it's like no it
personally happened in my reality you
know not
3 000 miles away yeah anything you know
and you're justified and feeling like
don't [ __ ] with me
yeah but like how even me in my reality
how can i say
someone in atlanta is my family yeah you
know when that happened like i
understand the tragedy
i understand the racial aspect of it i
understand
the implication of what this does to our
society in america
but damn it like yeah
we got our i we do have to live
our life and continue yeah going on yeah
yeah and i think like when people hear
that too
people kind of take it as uh something
as oh you
don't empathize with other people and
their pain it's like
no like i was kind of wrecked this
morning when i heard about it yeah of
course but
now i have to think about proactive
stuff in my life that i have to continue
and i'm and this is going to be on my
agenda too i'll i'm going to be a part
of that movement that's going to help
figure out this problem
you know but you can't but you can't
make an action without a plan
exactly let us make some plans
i don't know why people are so adverse
to
thought just do it
just jump wait wait wait
wait hold on like how come i can't take
the time
and think about what i'm going to say
how come i can't take the time to think
say that well do you do you need to take
time to take action
yes you do yeah because sometimes when
you react with the emotion which i've
done many times in my life you end up in
bad situations and you regret it and i
regret every
time yeah every time i have done that
multiple times and i've said a lot of
stupid things
which just because i take the time
doesn't mean i won't say something
stupid yeah but how i know how
media works how i know how emotions work
is that we when we go off
stuff that's kind of given to us in the
in the forefront
there's so much stuff that we're missing
because number one they don't they
choose not to put out that information
two things aren't out yet and three is
because i choose not to see it because
i'm mad
and we can't just make [ __ ] up based on
our feelings
exactly he must have done this he must
have done he must that he must
like it just happened guys yeah it just
happened
let's let's take some time to think
about it i'm not gonna do
an instagram post i'm not gonna go on a
rant i don't know what i'm talking about
yet
even in this conversation this
conversation specifically that we're
having on this podcast
is more about exploration than it is
about thought yeah it's i'm exploring
these ideas and things that i'm thinking
about but i'm not making really a
hardcore direct statement
i wonder if i say this is if people are
going to agree with it or not
yeah but you're allowed to think
otherwise the the reality of
you know the tragedy is that look
the vast majority of americans have no
idea about asian american hate yeah
right they don't
understand it at all you know and the
tragedy is
because asians are people too yeah
asians are humans
that they gotta see this [ __ ] happening
you know yeah of course asians are
humans
and then now the average american has to
think but why
are people killing them yeah why are
people attacking them it's this weird
position of like
i don't know if i've ever had to think
about my identity as i'm
as much as i've had to in the last few
years no kidding you know what i mean
like before i was just kind of living
life yeah i never had to think about
this concept
and now it's like do you know do we
wonder sometimes it's like
i'm starting to get that people don't
really think about us as much as we
think about them
you don't want to be there you know what
i'm laughing this circus you're right
yeah you know oh my god am i trying too
hard
yeah it's like dude like it's kind of
sad
it's yeah and that's actually the main
part of the problem it's like
we're trying to assimilate so hard yeah
are we not like the main part of the
problem is that
people don't give a [ __ ] about us you
and then we give too much [ __ ] about
them it's like yeah
it's this weird weird weird place to be
in and that's what it goes back to where
i talked about earlier in the podcast
about how sometimes i feel like we're
always being pushed and pulled apart
to be on other people's sides besides
our own agenda what is our agenda
like as a community what do we want from
other people
right and if we have that clear agenda
let's stick to it and let's build up on
that like number one
treat us as human beings number two
understand that we have our own issues
and problems that don't correlate with
your [ __ ] plight and your message we
have our own [ __ ] that we want to deal
with right you know
you know what's so [ __ ] funny there
was this girl that i roasted on
instagram
i don't remember her name but i call her
the notorious abg i don't remember
but she went on this rant um like
specifically stating that
uh you know like [ __ ] blm it's like
conspiracy [ __ ] or whatever
right and then she also kind of said
that black people are beneath
asian people and like do you see how you
guys behave that's why you're beneath us
and so i did that video talking about
how
uh you know how asian people should stop
being bullied or whatever right and she
goes
she like tags me and all the stuff and
everybody has tagged me in it
and she says see that's exactly what i
was saying years ago like a few months
ago and you were making fun of me and
i'm like
[ __ ] two different things
i wasn't saying that asian people don't
have problems i was saying time and
place
let's focus on this thing right now
where george all these people are being
murdered
and then we'll go to our stuff too it's
not supposed to be erased
i also never said that black americans
are beneath
other human beings you [ __ ] trash bag
and
and that's the exact problem that i'm
seeing as i was sifting through the news
about this shooting
the majority of the like i go through
many many different news sources but
like i was on twitter
and the majority of just what everyone
was saying is saying
this is a white supremacy problem or
this is a problem
of like black people actually attacking
asians or blaming and blaming and
blaming and blaming and blaming and
and that's the problem right right there
is to look at one another
and saying see this is a white thing see
this is a black thing and we were saying
at the very beginning
this is an american thing in this
[ __ ] country there's an american
thing yeah
right let's look at all of us we are
[ __ ] neighbors and we share this
space yeah it's not an
ethnicity thing it's a nation thing like
it's how this country views
asian americans right the entitlement of
colonization
right and also the the people who feel
like they should be first in line
that's the battle rather than look at us
yeah look at all of us
that's what i'm saying so let me just so
this is like some of the stuff like next
shot quoted her stuff okay
she goes she puts on her uh post where
she uh took a photo of a wall
and she goes real tired of this whole
black lives matter [ __ ]
how about saying all lives matter no
race is more superior than the other
i'm like that's not what black lives
matter she calls it the stupidest thing
ever
all lives matter no races more it's like
people have forgotten about how black
people were treating asians for kovid
i'm just upset at how it's focused on
one minority when [ __ ] was literally
just happening to asians for kobe but
you don't see us acting out like this
it's like talk wow yeah
of course of course they don't
understand what i'm saying saying it
definitely makes me want to stoop down
to their level
you're talking about black people
and this is even the level of where i'm
just like at speechless
where like it's tough it's just like
oh my god yeah yeah look at this not
even the worst like
i wish i would have screen kept what she
said before but she wrote
uh something way worse than that too she
was like saying like you see how you
guys act this is why you guys will never
get out of your situation
and and she wanted to say that we are
kindred spirits oh
stop we're no teams none of us i think
people need to realize that there's no
teams in america and in in the big point
of it like that's what i was mentioning
that
when people say whose problem this is
and like
when they say it as an affirmation like
see
white people hate asian see black people
hate agency
it's like no how america hates
everyone yeah america
hates everyone there is there is no
other country
like the the united states of america
that is so racially charged
yeah everything in this country deals
with race
right as much as politics are talked
about it it's
so hard to create
a system even beyond a system actually
not beyond like beneath that
is just a culture in this country where
we can really judge people for who they
are rather than what they look like yeah
because this country has been built on
that foundation and it's so hard to
reverse all those damages
like we can't we cannot
even get even this part annoys me right
i know i'm being a little picky here
i hate [ __ ] white apologists with as
much as i hate racist
i think that's cringy yeah why are you
apologizing
apologizing for like your ancestors
yeah shut the [ __ ] up it almost sounds
it almost sounds like a dave chappelle
sketch
like these guys that come up right like
there's you don't need a grovel
you know what it is too it's it's it's
because it's rooted in the uh
like i talked about this on a previous
podcast where it's about patting
yourself on the back
you know look at me i'm better than
these other white people you know it's
like
you don't have to do it by words just be
a decent person that's all people are
asking for
acknowledge some of the [ __ ] that
happened don't act like the history
never happened before and then just be a
decent person
i think they're just trying to bring out
the nobility in themselves people know
yes that's exactly what it is that oh
look how humble i can be
it's like it's basically like i know
somebody
who i see and every post that he puts is
about how white people should apologize
to black people
asian people and mexican people like you
need to apologize for your past sins
if once you recognize your the terrible
stuff that you've done now you need to
donate your money to all this it's like
boy hold on a second
i don't want that for my white brethren
no all right i just want
like i don't want anything specific
because i can't put out blanket
statements that all white people are
like this like
because you're white you're inherently
racist it's the idea of the personal
relationship yeah
you if he had white friends maybe he'd
go
he'd realize he doesn't have white
friends because he that's all he says to
white people
because you're an [ __ ] yeah that's
what you say when you meet a white guy
then maybe that's why you don't have
wifi
you know i don't need a white person to
come up and apologize to me because of
what your people have done it's like
yeah okay i won't ever get to know you
as a person you're groveling at my feet
for some [ __ ] that you personally didn't
do
you just had to acknowledge what other
people did before you and understand
that it was real
that's all and once you do that you'll
be respectful of somebody else's culture
that's all that it takes and i think if
people would realize that like i mean i
realized this because of that employee
that got shot
yeah that that's just his world yeah
that's all he knows
his first-hand experience of racism was
in my story when he sees it happening to
me and i sit there and i
explain to him you see what happened
there why didn't he
talk to you that way but it was just me
you know
like he had no problem with you at all
but you work here you know and
this was happening while you were around
but when i showed up it was a problem
yeah you know and he started to learn
these things
he was never exposed to it yeah like you
have to understand the majority
of america you know are just getting it
through tv and it's being spoof-fed
and shoved down with throats they don't
know they don't know
personal relationships matter like
living in these communities that you're
talking so much [ __ ] about
[ __ ] matters right and the reason why
it's because
you know people also also in the
comments they also mentioned this this
idea and this conversation
also too how your parents raise you
matters on
how how you deal with these certain
situations i know people who also grew
up in a black beauty supply store and
how they speak about the black community
is way different than how i speak about
right because of how my parents spoke
about the black community yeah so
they spoke about it as if they're people
yeah so
i their money is just as good as anyone
else that's what my mom says about the
method
nickel bag of just dump it that's funny
count it people are p people are people
people are people you know money
my parents always did a good job and
letting me know it's like hey a majority
of the people that come into this store
are going to be good people but we don't
know who those people are
so at the end of the day we're gonna
watch them but
at the same time know that about two
percent of the people are going to be
really bad to you yeah
but that's just them we have great
customers here we have great
relationships this is why we've been
allowed to stay in this neighborhood
without a majority of us having problems
because we're a staple here you know man
dude i gotta then
tell you about the story of another
person who has a store
out in the middle of nowhere whenever i
talk to them
they literally [ __ ] hate white people
straight up oh white people
white and what like when they say white
it's like white
yeah like that and they literally hate
them
you know and one of the things that i
had to go look
i've been attacked by many
white people okay yeah because i was in
the middle of nowhere but there's a lot
of
white people part of the therapy i had
to talk to i went straight to my
therapist and said
i don't want to hate white people
because i realize that the majority of
this company the company
country is white right
i can realize that [ __ ] in me if i start
generalizing
my entire neighborhood and the 300
customers i see a day
two of them are racist yeah right am i
gonna say
298 people like [ __ ] them all yeah
that's what i'm saying yeah i think
people need to realize
it when you say five percent of us are
asian
like however [ __ ] crazy amount is
white
and literally like then break it down
towards people who actually hate you see
that's the hard part right because when
i was reading these comments from these
asian
kids right who they are also inherently
racist to and they don't even know
they go see so do you still believe in
blm when you see
when i see this when i saw this
you know this one black individual when
i've dealt with
black my best friend is black yeah
am i supposed to ignore all this great
stuff
am i supposed to ignore the text message
that i've gotten from my black friend
saying hey
yo i've i've heard about the stuff like
yo we support you we got
am i supposed to ignore that just
because i saw this one article i'm gonna
take that situation seriously yeah
i'm not gonna judge a whole group of
people by this individual's actions yeah
right because what's your best friend
doing his own thing
exactly his own thing and then you start
going to him about your like asian
problems against
like whatever community or whatever but
or like the fact that you share personal
relationship
and life together you know the things
that you're allowed to share
and i don't want to have like my white
friends like come up and you know
just always feel like they're on thin
ice it's like man dude like
i hate this [ __ ] man that's the worst
yeah i hate going into a conversation
like in a liberal art room
and the white people are like um i don't
know if i'm allowed to say this
yeah or they start apologizing before
they say something i really
want the freedom for them to just speak
as well i had a homie
recently we were eating and um
at this asian restaurant outdoors they
give you a fork
or they give you chopsticks you could
tell this [ __ ] has been wrecked
by a lot of this like
you know just being sensitive about like
asian rhetoric yeah and this fool was
like
hey man pause but i'm probably use a
fork and i'm like
what about you are you apologizing
and i looked it up i was like bro if you
picked up those chopsticks and you
couldn't use it i would have laughed at
you for a [ __ ] hour
yeah use the [ __ ] fork yeah you know
he's like what are you using i'm like
why does it matter yeah
[Laughter]
are we doing the same action of you know
putting some sustenance into our bodies
for energy you know do we step out
here's the thing too it's like this like
do you act like when you walk into an
asian restaurant if you don't use a
chopstick like our ancestors are gonna
come out from the grave
is that going to happen it's not going
to happen yeah that's your [ __ ] fork
stop struggling like i see like i see
sometimes these like white people
they're trying to eat like rice with
chopsticks i'm like bro that's just hard
yeah you know
torture yourself you're not even
enjoying the fact the food that's good
for you it's like the food's cold now
because you can't because you can't eat
your rice
just [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast i hope you
enjoyed that conversation
uh leaving your uh comments uh below
if you guys disagree or agree you can
catch us every thursday and sundays
uh you could catch ed at ed parkvp on
instagram he had his own podcast where
you could hear his own personal stories
uh bible study at momo bible study at
momo check that out and we'll see you
all
next time peace